so you see here is a clip that was
apparently leaked what
we're going to break down the video
pixel by pixel to determine its
authenticity is it possible that the
shot was faked or is it real
nothing gets fans more excited than
crossovers the avengers
wandaverse when the guy who played
quicksilver played quicksilver but he
was from the other franchise what
dude the spider-verse movies what turns
out they're doing it in live action now
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly level
i'm gonna put some dirt in your eye
so you see here is a clip that was
apparently leaked obviously showing
andrew garfield on set as his character
from the amazing spider-man series it's
weird when a video clip like this comes
out it's very clearly andrew garfield
yet he turns around and says no it is
not i
i heard about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop who do you believe
here's what people are saying online
about this it's been revealed that
andrew garfield's appearance in the
latest spider-man movie was in fact a
deep fake the hollywood star who played
the webb's slinging superhero in the
last movie will not be reprising his
role after producers discovered he had
been replaced by an ai trained to
impersonate the actor we were having a
difficult time with andrew garfield who
couldn't get him to come to set and
sometimes filming would be delayed
because of his commitments to some movie
about a quadriplegic single mother
anyways
anyways the the article goes on but it
proves the point that this video of
andrew garfield is fake
that article is fake similarly generated
it with an ai much like the actual
articles written about this subject that
seemed to be written by ai
so sam and i are going to cut through
that conflicting information today we're
going to break down the video pixel by
pixel to determine its authenticity is
it possible that the shot was faked or
is it real so come with us through the
critical thinking process so next time
something like this happens you can
figure it out for yourself
so what's interesting is that it looks
like this is an actual cinema camera or
a rather high quality camera it's a
large sensor because you can see some
depth of field here this isn't like some
person on their phone either it's like
some ripped footage from a
behind-the-scenes crew or someone who
has like tapped into one of the actual
monitors on set this could just be
footage from when he was filming
spider-man and he's just talking to his
stunt double like do you want me to
stand like you were standing like this
all right so if we compare that footage
with the original footage from the
amazing spider-man there's a pretty big
difference between the two his hairdo is
different he looks a lot younger he
looks like he's in high school but main
thing is his hair dude like they
wouldn't just have a different hairdo
for one day on set here so this this
most likely is new footage
his face looks like it's a different
resolution from his costume slightly
blurrier there does seem to be a slight
lack of detail there it's a bit of an
anomaly in my opinion because if we're
looking at like the bars there we can
see like surface imperfections on the
beams and it does seem like there's a
slight lack of quality on the face that
being said like generally if you upload
a video to a social media platform the
chances that it's going to be a mp4 file
it's it's pretty likely and the way mp4
files work is by compressing
motion
into an overall image so it's less about
rendering an unique frame every single
frame but taking
one frame and then basically saying all
right this is the direction the pixels
are moving so that way we have motion
data instead of image data it's called
iframes and p frames so an example like
this if you export a three second clip
everything that's not moving is going to
stay
crisp while the things moving will have
less fidelity
the main claim i've seen made about this
video is that we are in fact looking at
a deep fake of andrew garfield i don't
think this is a deep fake this would be
the best defect i've ever seen if it's a
deep fake 100
i mean the best defense i've ever seen
is the tom cruise deep fakes what's up
tick tock deep tom cruise by chris kumay
i mean those are wonderful but you can
tell the deep fix if you scrutinize it
you can see there's no crisp shadow
under the nose from the sunlight there's
a bit of a sense of like his face is
being lit and then like re-lit again
i feel
uh
fresh
there's a button
but even like the teeth like the
lighting on the teeth is not quite right
also you can see it feels a little bit
like it's a flat texture of a face you
know as opposed to like a
three-dimensional object so that's
because the computer is trained on a
bunch of images of a face well those
images are filmed at all different focal
lengths you know oftentimes if you're
doing say you know training from movies
like let's say we're doing a tom cruise
deep fake and you're grabbing all these
tom cruise shots so a lot of times
you're using close-ups close-ups are
often shot with the telephoto lens and
what a telephoto lens does is it tends
to flatten everything so my face has a
lot of distortion right my nose is
scaled up a little bit because it's
closer to you my ears my face is
probably kind of like a little fish-eyed
and these get a little bit smaller get
perspective on my face
now you'll kind of see how everything's
flattened on my face and you've probably
seen like the gifs of this on reddit or
something like that like look at what
lenses do to the face what ends up
happening is that when you put a deep
dick on the face you kind of get this
weird like flat nose effect or like the
whole face is almost like this like
squished lack of perspective almost like
orthographic view when in real life
should actually be getting a lot more
perspective and depth and almost like
vanishing points representing themselves
on the face as the geometry moves around
it's really really really good but just
scrutinize it it's not quite right that
in mind let's go back to andrew garfield
whoa
hey guys it's me brandy garfield as you
can see i'm on the set of man who acts
like a spider i don't really know what
number it is but i'm here and i'm happy
to be here and i'm even more happy to
tell you about today's sponsor
expressvpn
guys if you aren't using a vpn when
you're out surfing the open internet you
should really be considering it as one
of the most valuable tools to protect
your information and give you access to
content from all over the world you see
the first thing that a vpn does is it
reroutes your internet connection to a
server in another location this gives
your data additional encryption when it
is out on the open internet so that
hackers cannot steal your information
and your internet service provider
cannot take your data and sell it to
third parties for advertisements and if
there's one thing that i don't like it's
bad guys and the second thing that a vpn
is gonna do for you is it's gonna give
you access to content from all over the
world that's one of my favorite features
about expressvpn you see the way that it
works is if you're on a platform like
netflix they're going to give you access
to certain movie titles that are only
available in the country that you're in
but with a vpn you can tell websites
that you are accessing the internet from
an entirely different country which is
going to give you all the movie titles
that are available on a platform like
netflix in an entirely different country
meaning you can access content from all
over the world now guys if you don't
believe me just go on the reviews and
check out expressvpn for yourself they
were rated number one by platforms like
cnet and tech radar i know that i might
have a perfect jawline but one thing
that's more perfect than my jawline is
expressvpn's 24 7 customer service
they're also the fastest vpn provider
out there it's really beautiful i use it
all the time now if you're interested
you can get three months free by
clicking the link in the description
below or going to
expressvpn.com
core or crew that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn
corridor crew oh
oh they're calling me back to set guys
hey this is just another day in the life
of a hollywood movie star until next
time you have fun with that vpn and uh
i gotta go get this shot see you guys
later
the first thing i'm seeing is there's an
edge light coming from the top right
corner kind of a bluish daylight blue
edge light it's hitting the the lines on
his costume it's also hitting the side
of his neck at the corner of his jaw and
his hair here a little bit of the corner
of the jaw cash from the light is
interesting because that specific kind
of sharp lighting detail that's
something a deep fake does not do very
well most deep fakes cover this part of
the face you can do whole head deep
fakes but they get blurry and low
resolution so that would mean that the
hair has to be real you almost never
deep fake hair it's very very hard to do
especially especially such bountiful
hair like that from your garfield
another thing to look at is the eyes so
your eyes are reflective they're spheres
the reflections in both eyes should be
consistent with each other if one eye
shows one light reflection the other eye
shows two light reflections well then
that's a sign that the eyes are being
faked and deep fake only picked up on
one of the bright spots looking at his
eyes i see consistent reflections in
both another thing i'm seeing the
sharpness of the shadows going off of
his nose on the side of his face and
more importantly into his mouth you can
see the glistening light on the water of
his tongue and it's consistent the deep
fake might catch that here and there but
it has no idea of what's causing
highlights or light it just knows
statistically where these things go
you'd have to have so much very specific
trained data of andrew garfield's tongue
with light glistening on it at the
correct color type return angle to be
able to replicate it here i mean if the
andrew garfield shot is a deep fake
maybe somebody's just thought it'd be a
funny joke to fake this i mean there are
good deep fake artists out there that
could theoretically do something like
this yeah well as real as this looks
it has been revealed that this shot
is a deep fake
[Music]
oh yeah right
i can't tell this is fake the puppet
the puppet
that's the pro that's the clearest sign
that this is fake already he's like you
would never why would you move his arm
up to the pole
i can tell amelia's to say no but look
they defeat this see how the track
the lips and the nose and the eyes are
being tracked all right alex serrato is
trolling all of us he's even come out
and said as much on his youtube channel
all right so the big giveaway here for
me is this deep fake training grid so
when you have this grid view one set of
faces is the face that's going to be put
on the other person the other set of
faces is the person who will be
receiving the face in other words this
shouldn't all be andrew garfield one row
should be andrew garfield and the other
row should be the actor underneath
that's that's the funny thing he's
training his deep fake on the final
image
yeah so where's the other actor because
you don't just like it doesn't generate
a face from nothing that's i think it's
really funny i love that alex did this
but i think that
the number of news articles that went
out saying it turns out oh it turns out
it was a deep fake after all they just
point to this it's like all they had to
do was show the training shot to one
person who's ever done a deep dick in
their life and they would immediately
know it's not real there is one thing
about this that caught me like well
that's weird when he enhances the face
and it's the way his teeth jump around
when it's enhanced here so what's
happening here is he's using an ai up
resin algorithm here that's looking at
the face and it's analyzing detail and
filling in extra detail and so the
reason the wrinkles are moving on the
lips or the way the teeth the heights
are shifting is it's identifying
patterns and it's guessing yeah maybe
this is the top of the tooth and then a
few frames later it goes no this is the
top of the tooth and so the tooth
constantly jumps around all the details
are not temporally consistent as we
would say now in a real deep fake this
is something you would actually run into
you would run into the teeth shimmying
around a little bit you run into the
wrinkles on the lips shimming around a
little bit all right so this video is
fake but are there any other ways one
could fake this video without using a
deep fake this could be andrew garfield
cut out from a film and they set up the
shot to like look like it that's how i
would fake it like i would find a shot
of andrew garfield where i can match the
lighting and like the motions and i just
cut it out and stick it onto my footage
you get pretty close i mean here's the
thing at the end of the day could this
be faked yes this could be faked it
would be
very very very very very good fakery
i don't think it's a deep fake t-picks
are not magic they're really not that
crazy they require a ton of artistry to
actually blend and look real also it's
probably not even a leak like at this
point if i was a movie studio what's
gonna get more pressed like an actual
official photo that's released or a
leaked one you tell me i'm not supposed
to see this
you know it's like it's like i'm totally
clicking on that yeah i mean they just
got us to talk about this for a whole
video look at that right
hashtag
ad
question
so this video was brought to you by
disney and spider-man no way home and we
even have a special additional clip for
you guys to check out of the film here
it is
everyone's got super powers
well everyone but me
great character great superhero i love
the original movies with tobey maguire
all the spider-man movies they're super
fun and would it be exciting to see one
where all the cast members from
different films come together for a
single hit uh yeah it would be super
cool thanks for watching everybody
really appreciate it so we really enjoy
doing these debunk videos i have to give
a massive shout out to captain
disillusion not that we're trying to
copy his format but if there's anybody
out there who does the best debunk
videos on the internet it's him if you
like this video go check them out but
i'd love some more clips you know
like real footage real footage ghost
footage the bigfoot footage point us to
some very specific shots that you want
to see us take a look at to see if we
can spot any residual artifacts of
visual effects artistry or we can try to
figure out if they are exactly 100 real
we'll find your mysteries and we'll
solve them
hey look someone's on the ground
hey what's up hey look it's not
spiderman
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]